tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo video
sono fa vj ed oggi siamo su youtube live
credo che sia un misto tra youtuber
simulator che quello che avete visto
l'altra volta è the sims forse non lo so
non sono sicuro la venue game è la
madonna anche la cinematica è sta roba
lo youtuber più popolare addirittura
alla madonna mi spiegate che pescarolo e
stato un lungo e difficile viaggio e fa
bene c'è una festa è lui che fa gameplay
questa è la mia storia con la festa in
casa e lui in camera sulla fare gameplay
applausi prova vedere se riesco a fare
me stesso ragazzi prova almeno oggi ore
g'ha ol trovato de carli e lui è più o
meno regali
ci siamo ma di volontà gioca batini
osceno fashion lifestyle cooking music
sono comin sun
per il resto c'è games e interior name
fa vj name of channel fa vj tv ci siamo
perfetti
diamo un'occhiata alle prime cose che ho
imparato prima di diventare lo youtuber
numero 1 shoes game a bello ce n'è solo
uno empyre planet 2 state video ma
veramente va quanto figo microphones
degli occhi che puoi cambiare anche il
microfono bellissimo e ha il nome del
video il mio primo video di merda tech
la tua base è stata devo pure giocare ma
la madonna quanto sono figo a carissimo
next e va bene poiché montare i video
bellissimo e geniali sto gioco basta
come ho fatto uno scoprirlo prima tac
tac è vai mint è proprio così facile
editare video ve lo giuro ci metto
proprio così poco tempo io questo
ragazzo è giusto per farvi capire la
differenza tra i tagli che ho fatto per
montare questo video che state vedendo e
i tagli che invece fanno vedere nel
video game è la stessa cosa praticamente
il mio primo vita di merda fantastico
video quali ti sei in realtà la
miniatura fa un po cagare prove quello è
un altro discorso
il mio primo video di merda ha avuto
successo discreto o un testo ogni mese
quindi devo studiare se lo passo
riceverà un premio
ma se lo fallisco mia madre questa è la
storia della mia vita sul serio ragazzi
per andare a scuola devo semplicemente
uscire dalla porta della mia stanza
va bene se sei bravo come me a studiare
zio se nella merda e te lo dico però 6
visualizzazioni 7 visualizzazioni 10 11
sono andato alla scuola fa chi è ho
fatto 20 visualizzazioni come son
contento shopping use your pc al posso
anche fare shopping su steam ma
chiaramente ma quanto figure sto gioco
su pc vuole trovo le nuove nuovi pezzi
nel computer fantastico provo a giocarlo
seriamente per iniziare a fare lo
youtube e rio la prima cosa che
prenderei ragazzi guardate st
videocamera la vedete
ecco il successo è assicurato ne compro
2 avendo tutti i soldi che ciò 84 ci sto
ancora dentro la tastiera e arriviamo a
100 ma non posso permettermi altro per
adesso comprarlo non c'è più un soldo ma
almeno ciò attrezzatura è quanto ci
metteranno ad arrivare ok ce la farò
ragazzi oddio è arrivato è la madonna
che corriere che ciò è la webcam o
perfetto
fantastico non ci posso credere mai
trovare in mente in questo momento sto
tizio cia l'attrezzatura migliore della
mia in un secondo
stai perdendo iscritti dovresti fare più
video e minchia un attimo ho comprato
tutto è madre fuori da camera mia devo
fare video la scuola ha chiamato ha
detto che hai perso un sacco di lezioni
madre devo fare video non rompe rigo
allora proviamoci lega
va bene il suo tipo video gameplay
perfetto dato non mi sono neanche mai
presentato col mio canale nome del video
il primo video non era male ma questo è
meglio io sì che sono youtuber che sa
fare le cose i tuoi alleati ti hanno
tradito a 29 nostra cosa non l'avevo
vista processo bello sarà una roba
interessantissima la madonna video
quality 0 lava ragazzi perché possiamo
andare a dormire perché i due video in
un giorno più lo studio mi hanno
massacrato quindi let's go to dormire mi
chiedo c'è il sonno leggero però si
comments anche ai commenti no vabbè il
gameplay di empire planet sono molto
interessanti adesso la qualità fa
veramente schifo caitlin caitlin non
capisci un cazzo di computer non mi
veniva di come fai video madre farmi un
panino che ho fame non poteva la sua
casa devo fare assolutamente un video
mentre guardo i panni stesi fanno madre
mia madre cosa fa il madre è tra di fare
questioni del cazzo è incazzata perché
non ho studiato lo adesso studiamo e non
si deve incazzare so anche andando a
studiare sono un bravo ragazzo io
dai facciamo un po di romanticismo
koncar lei è veramente una [ __ ]
arriviamo al massimo del rapporto questa
bella gnocca e poi ripenso agli iscritti
ma che posso fare tutti insieme un
massimo di rapporto avere un amico come
te ma no ma come mia freddo nato subito
facciamo un video su un gioco diverso
empire planet ragazzi mi hanno free enzo
nato si vede come pio e views grande
azzeccatissimo hai trovato un oggetto
segreto è non posso mettere niente
perché non posso mettere più niente
perché non ho più idee alla barra delle
idee va avanti mica che casino
montiamo il video così c'è solo una cosa
vabbè soft focus ovviamente un video
dove parlo di cose e di king processo è
la madonna video quality 15 dai ragazzi
pubblici video questo qua mi fa un sacco
di views magno qualcosa vado a dormire
che ne dite
posso mangiare fuori
i ragazzi mi hanno fantastico spero che
mi video possono essere belli come
questo congratulazioni grazie amelia non
posso credere che questo sia
autoproclami youtuber che fa così schifo
nel l'editing vago o già gli haters lega
non ha ancora iniziato a fa esordi come
è possibile se questa persona e lo
youtube e rio sono batman ma [ __ ]
brutta try and work ma c'è anche lavoro
consegna i giornali 6 ore dai fantastico
da fare questo così più i soldi che mi
compro i giochi nuovi c'è non solo uno e
fa cagare dio mio primo a fare un po di
roba alla visco comprende i giochi nuovi
o 30 dollari 30 dollari celio quindi
posso comprare a broken world suoi
uscito da poco dai compro compro veloce
perfetto regalo grave la madonna è anche
tempo di andare a prendere la fiesta nel
frigo è arrivato il fatto subito
fallisce o minchia finalmente non vedevo
l'ora gazo start video minghi e
finalmente in altro gioco perfetto i
video e questo video fa un sacco de vue
market bello epic games e passion
perfetto con fanny com perfetto già
finisce hai messo pochissimo quanto 2
rostovi di un minuto e mezzo
vabbè ci sto mettendo degli effetti
completamente a caso regalo le video è
la madonna 19 video quali the script 4
active 5 6 7 os produzione danno un
genio dell'editing real publicis video
sembra che il mio pc via dei problemi
non che questo successo che se scassato
il pc ma spera che sta caricando il
video non fanno lo smonta adesso non ce
la fa per 20 dollari
scegli 20 dollari ma non ce li avevo
vabbè salve è il tipo che di riparare
bello che il tipo che ripara il computer
che si sta facendo mi sta creando il
canale
c'era una saetta dentro il di computer e
lui al caseggiato su facebook va bene
quante views quanto famoso ci credo ma
guarda quanta roba madre che è questo
chi cazzo è questo è una tipa a caso è
entrata una tipo e camera mia ma come
mamma non entrare per le prossime due o
tre ore
non oso cazzola ha funzionato pure
questa altre mi prendono vita e la
storia della mia vita sul serio la madre
non mi aiuta mai vero madre nora adesso
che sta arrivando il pacco di amazon
league of giants il gameplay veloce che
dice league of giants dico già va
assolutamente che è uscito oggi non
rompe il cazzo madre devo fare i video
su league of lions mic è incredibile che
ti te lo posso fare che che mi fa fare
vi uso a carissimo ronaldo totti in a
break parchi è a minchia come l'ho
trovato subito il titolo giusto e un
video corto mano allora facciamo mar
dello sluc poi mar dello slot perfetto
vediamo quanto fatto e la madonna nava
bagnare gara mentre si carica il video
tanto ce la faccio madre sto per andare
a studiare così sei contenta cui
carriera è bellissimo soggiorno open
source e così figo il bello è che puoi
fare un sacco di gol ancora stati pazzi
mancuso in camera che voi si è cosa è
successo
gliel'ha data lo so perché perché felice
era felice a un certo punto 24 dollari
quanti soldi
quante viuzze quanto famoso e mi sono
montato la testa e la fama mi cambia un
altro video di league of giants subito
subito lo voglio che in play subitissimo
me l'ha data perfetto questo è il titolo
del video 11 ore di rendering madonna e
la madre va bene quanto bello sto video
pare che a 1.800 iscritti non lavora che
ho visto sono tantissimi per aver appena
iniziato vuoi parlare è veri sono certo
che parliamo dove devi aspettare che il
video vabbè mica checa che cambia non
puoi chattare se carica al video scusami
che cazzo di computer ciai e vai a
dormire zio che stai messo male madonna
ma questo non dorme da una vita
non c'è tempo di parlarsi e mi dispiace
sacco di volte avrei voluto rimorchia ma
non ci avevo tempo regga
mi hanno detto l'esperienza perché ora
raggiunti traguardi non sapevo
pessimo eve non lo sapevo se potesse
rosa sono a livello 3 me l'ha data sta
finendo di caricare vai così che c'è
questa ciao fa vigeva invitarti ad un
film domani sera va bene ma che gran
figata una tipa entrate in camera mia
chiedendomi di andare a vedere un film
ma quanti bei commenti nell'ultimo video
vestirmi dai madre che mai invitato una
[ __ ] cosa vuoi
cosa fa cosa fa mia madre è scema è
scema casa fa no non è vero
per due giorni in tre computer ma sei
scema madre stai perdendo iscritti no
non è vero ma da novanta ha fatto il
video però la odio lo stesso ma che
cazzo fai sono youtuber di successo io
non puoi fare queste cose deve riparare
il computer che palle by zio e tutto tuo
non mi a creare il canale brutto stronzo
non ci ha messo sto tizio che puoi
andare a studiare tornare madonna levi
levarti non tifare mia madre che mi
invece nome del vito allora un tecnico
si è fatto mia madre è pubblici vito
vabbè ragazzi vado a dormire e signori e
signore i 5 mila iscritti siamo arrivati
al primo traguardo deve arrivare a meno
milione non ci arriverò mai nella vita
però ci prova
oggi invece che il canale 30.000 views 5
mila iscritti 41 dollari
va bè ragazzi che un proprio il primo
episodio di youtubers life che è un
casino ma veramente danno peso fosse
così tecnico ma è veramente figo
niente ci vediamo forse episodio un bel
like per questo evito game è piccolo
dove arrivarono sfondare i like devo
vederlo esplodere i live e video è
semplice i ragazzi consente se vi è
piaciuto argomento è un mi piace anche
la passione di facebook e quindi io
totale iscrizione senza vestiti
scalatrici vediamo fosse un video bella
ragazza